braun und alte menschen die
von russland verbreitete zynische
behauptung es handle sich bei diesem
thema um eine inszenierung fällt auf
diejenigen zurück die diese lügen
verbreiten die ermordung von zivilisten
ist ein kriegsverbrechen
um es klar zu sagen die täter und ihre
auftraggeber müssen zur rechenschaft
gezogen werden darum unterstützen wir
alle internationalen bemühungen solche
greueltaten nun - zu dokumentieren und
schonungslos aufzuklären in butter und
auch darüber hinaus
das sollten wir ja nicht vergessen wir
müssen ja damit rechnen dass wir noch
weitere solche bilder sehen werden auch
die europäische union hat der ukraine
alle hilfe in dieser angelegenheit
zugesagt
meine damen und herren unterdessen geht
das töten des russischen militärs weiter
unvermindert
und deshalb fordere ich an dieser stelle
noch einmal den russischen präsidenten
auf
beenden sie diesen zerstörerischen und
selbstzerstörerischen krieg sofort
ziehen sie ihre truppen aus der ukraine
ab
und bis das geschieht setzen wir
weiterhin alles daran die ukraine
bestmöglich zu unterstützen
immer abgestimmt mit unseren freunden
und verbündeten
dazu gehört auch
dass wir aus den aktuellen beständen der
bundeswehr an waffen liefern können
alles das was sinnvoll ist und schnell
wirkt das wird geliefert
ich weiß das
bundesverteidigungsministerium christine
lambrecht alles unternimmt das
angesichts der beschlusslage unserer
alliierten und mit blick auf die fähig
so dass das signal leider abgebrochen
wir bitten das zu entschuldigen
es liegt leider nicht in unseren händen
weiterhin natürlich jan schäfer was
kannst du schon was sagen zu den ersten
worten von olaf scholz sehr gut es waren
deutliche worte das war nochmal ganz
klar der appell wurde den namen putin
nicht in den mund genommen hat an den
russischen präsidenten so hat es olaf
scholz gesagt stoppen sie endlich diesen
krieg und er hat sich noch einmal auch
vor seine sehr umstrittene
bundesverteidigungsminister in christine
lambrecht gestellt noch einmal gesagt
wir liefern zurzeit aus den bundeswehr
beständen alles was an gefragt wird was
auch die nato-partner anfrage also hat
er da diesbezüglich noch mal deutlich
den rücken gestärkt ein punkt das haben
wir gerade diskutiert hat bei uns haben
wir ja auch noch einmal gesagt es müssen
den worten die es gab auch wieder taten
folgen wenn diese waffen jetzt geliefert
werden dann werden das auf jeden fall
taten signal ist wieder da wir können
wieder rein
hunderttausende kriegsflüchtlinge aus
der ukraine sind in den letzten wochen
nach deutschland gekommen und es werden
mehr werden
sie sind hier willkommen das will ich an
dieser stelle noch einmal sagen
und wir werden gemeinsam mit den ländern
in deutschland morgen wichtige
entscheidungen treffen was all die
fragen betrifft die damit zusammenhängen
registrierung unterbringung und
natürlich auch die gemeinsame
finanzierung
gesamtstaatliche aufgaben auch dies als
eine bemerkung von mir ich wünsche mir
dass wir nicht eine ewig lange
diskussionen über die finanziellen
fragen zwischen den verschiedenen ebenen
unseres landes haben sondern dass wir
uns schnell und zügig einigen zwischen
dem bund den ländern dass wir die
interessen der kommunen und landkreise
hier
berücksichtigen dass wir eine gute
einigung und verständigung haben damit
wir uns der eigentlichen aufgabe
zuwenden können wir helfen wir den
flüchtlingen die hier schutz gesucht
haben
und für uns alle sollte ein ansporn sein
die solidarität die die bürgerinnen und
bürger dieses landes jeden tag zeigen
denn es gibt sehr viel solidarität sehr
viel unterstützung überall in
deutschland und ich bin sehr dankbar
dafür diese hilfe ist wichtig und sie
tut gut
und schließlich werden wir den druck auf
russland weiter erhöhen zum beispiel mit
den sanktionen die wir auf den weg
gebracht haben die sind lange
vorbereitet lange bevor der krieg
ausgebrochen worden gebrochen ist haben
wir darüber gesprochen
wir haben sie
vereinbart mit der eu-kommission und wir
sind dabei die aktuellen sanktionen noch
einmal zu verschärfen das fünfte paket
ist in der finalen debatte und es wird
noch einmal präzise dazu beitragen dass
russland die folgen dieses krieges spürt
auch um zu erreichen dass es den krieg
beendet
es muss unser ziel bleiben dass russland
diesen krieg nicht gewinnt das ist das
was hinter den aktivitäten steht die wir
unternehmen wenn es nun um waffen die
führung geht wenn es um finanzielle und
humanitäre unterstützung geht wenn es um
die aufnahme der flüchtlinge geht oder
um die sanktions pakete die wir global
und wird weltweit vereinbaren und
natürlich gehört dazu auch dass wir die
abhängigkeiten reduzierenden dem wir uns
heute befinden
und dazu gehört natürlich auch die
reduktion der abhängigkeit vom import
russischer energie
wir wissen alle diese abhängigkeiten
sind über jahrzehnte gewachsen und sie
lassen sich nicht von einem tag auf den
anderen beenden
deshalb ist es sehr sehr wichtig dass
wir uns in europa gemeinsam auf den weg
gemacht haben genau das zu schaffen und
gemeinsam einen kurs abgesteckt haben
mit dem wir das auch tatsächlich tun
jetzt während dieses krieges aber die
weichen sind gestellt und sie werden
auch nach dem krieg weiter einen den
kurs vorgeben den wir zu gehen haben und
gleichzeitig geht es nicht nur darum
neue import linien möglich zu machen und
neue importkapazitäten und neue
vertragspartner zu
[Musik]
interessant olaf scholz spricht nicht
von einem stopp der gas- und
öllieferungen aus russland er spricht
davon die abhängigkeit von russland zu
reduzieren dass es genau wieder das was
wir in den vergangenen wochen ja von ihm
auch immer gehört hat es ist nicht der
knallharten schritt es ist wieder ein
bisschen die bremse und dass es nicht
das was sich viele europäische partner
und schon gar nicht die ukraine von
deutschland gewünscht hatte ausbauen die
dazu erforderlich sind wir werden die
import strukturen für kohle öl und gas
so organisieren dass wir auf dauer nicht
mehr abhängig sind von den russischen
importen das werden wir mit nie
gekannter geschwindigkeit tun und heute
hat das kabinett dazu einen ganz
wichtigen beitrag geleistet
mit einer entscheidung die ohnehin zu
den plänen dieser regierung zählte und
diese sorgfältig vorbereitet haben aber
die jetzt unbedingt und noch viel mehr
notwendig ist mit dem oster paket zum
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien in
deutschland zur stärkung der
energienetze zeigen wir was wir vorhaben
jetzt erst recht werden wir uns
unabhängig machen von der nutzung
fossiler ressourcen das ist unsere
aufgabe
vielen dank bevor wir mit der befragen
beginn ein paar vorbemerkung von mir wir
haben jetzt über die fraktionen bereits
sehr viele wortmeldungen
gemeldet bekommen und in der kanzler
oder kanzlerin befragung ist es
üblicherweise so dass wir so verfahren
dass wir die fragesteller aufrufen dass
eine nachfrage gestellt werden kann ich
aber üblicherweise dann nicht mehr
weitere fragen über andere fraktionen
zum thema zu lassen sondern wir dann in
die nächst in den nächsten frage block
gehen nur dass das einmal noch mal
erklärt wird weil wir das bei anderen
befragung ja durchaus anders machen in
dem dann auch das fragerecht auf andere
fraktion übergeht zum gleichen thema
das einleitend noch mal damit dass für
alle fraktionen klar ist und ich rufe
zuerst zur befragung auf den kollegen dr
johann wadephul für die cdu/csu-fraktion
kanzler zum thema waffenlieferung hat
sich der vorsitzende der grünen in
deutschland omid nouripour den
vergangenen tagen geäußert und er hat
dazu gesagt dass die leistung der
bundesverteidigungsministerium christine
lambrecht sehr unzureichend sei weil
keine hinreichende
synchronisation zwischen den wünschen
der ukraine und den möglichkeiten
deutschlands waffen zu liefern
stattfindet teilen sie diese auffassung
und wenn ja was gedenken sie zu tun um
die missstände abzustellen sie haben
vorsitzenden der gründen völlig
missverstanden ich hatte gestern das
privileg mit ihm länger ein gespräch zu
führen oder hat mir das gegenteil gesagt
gerade für sie können eine nachbarin
würde dann die nachfrage darzustellen
wie hat er ihnen denn sein zusatz
erklärt dass er in dem gleichen
interview darauf hingewiesen hat dass
größere mengen schützenpanzer marder
herr umständen die in die ukraine
verbracht werden könnten und wo dies
nicht geschehe und ich verbinde das mit
dem hinweis dass es mehrere
rüstungsunternehmen in deutschland gibt
die anfragen von der ukraine haben dass
waffen geliefert werden könnten die
ukraine zahlungsbereit ist es aber an
genehmigungen seitens ihrer regierung
fehlt was sagen sie dazu ich möchte
gerne noch einmal darauf hinweisen dass
es ein bruch mit langen tradition ist
dass diese regierung anders als alle
ihre vorgängerinnen entschieden hat
überhaupt waffen in die ukraine und in
ein krisengebiet zu liefern das ist eine
richtige entscheidung die wir abgewogen
aber auch schnell getroffen haben es ist
interessant zu beobachten dass viele ddr
entscheidungen der vergangenheit bisher
immer unterstützt hatten jetzt plötzlich
alle möglichen vorschläge haben wie es
jetzt weitergehen soll aber der
eigentliche weg die eigentliche
entscheidung war die dass wir es
überhaupt tun und jetzt nutzen wir
unsere möglichkeiten das machen wir
einerseits abgestimmt mit unseren
freundinnen und freunden in der nato und
der europäischen union weil es darum
geht dass alle in gleicher richtung
gehen und nicht unterschiedliche
aktivitäten unternehmen zweiter treffen
wir diese entscheidung nach sorgfältiger
vorbereitung in den dazu notwendigen
gremien wo wir auch dafür sorgen dass
die sicherheit der bundesrepublik
deutschland dabei sorgfältig beachtet
wird und im übrigen ist es so dass wir
dabei alles was richtig und sinnvoll ist
auf den weg bringen
frau präsidentin meine
ja das ist aber ich erwarte dann auch
eine antwort auf meine frage und ich
habe darauf hingewiesen dass
sie haben ja meine antwort auf diese
frage bekommen allerdings müssen sie
sich noch mit dem thema beschäftigen
warum sie die politik der
bundesregierung die sie jetzt
unterstützen nicht richtig gefunden
haben früher zu anderen zeiten waren sie
früher war gerade vor bitte ich weiß
aber sie haben eine nachfrage und sie
können ja nachher nochmal über die
nächsten fragesteller nachhaken die
nächste kolleginnen die die frage stellt
ist vieles polat von bündnis 90 die
grünen
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr bundeskanzler scholz ich
möchte romani rose zitieren romani rose
ist vorsitzender des zentralrats
deutscher sinti und roma und er warnte
erst kürzlich vor der ungleichbehandlung
von geflüchteten
romney und bezeichnete die bisher
bekannten einzelfälle von
diskriminierung als besorgniserregend er
drückt er drückte seine erwartung aus
dass jetzt zitiere ich dass unser staat
ukrainischen roma die als
kriegsflüchtlinge nach deutschland
kommen den gleichen schutz gewährt
bekommen wie alle anderen ukrainischen
staatsbürger innen aus wird sich unsere
bundesregierung genauso
gegenüber den ukrainischen roma kümmern
wie es für die anderen ukrainischen
geflüchtete aus der ukraine vorgesehen
ist
schönen dank für ihre frage in der tat
gibt es darum dass wir hier allen
gleichermaßen gerecht werden das haben
wir mit der entscheidung da die
europaweit getroffen worden ist und die
in deutschland eben auch besondere
großzügige weise auch ausgelegt worden
ist wir haben möglich gemacht dass
diejenigen hier einreisen können die
ukrainische staatsbürger sind und das
gilt für die von ihnen
genannten genauso wie für alle anderen
und darüber hinaus möglich gemacht dass
auch diejenigen die aufrechte zum
beispiel in der ukraine haben ebenfalls
hier einreisen können unabhängig von
ihrer staatsbürgerschaft um dieses bat
ihre ihrer frage nicht ging aber das
finde ich muss bei dieser gelegenheit
gesagt werden und deshalb kann ich ihnen
versichern die bundesregierung wird
alles dafür tun dass niemand
diskriminiert wird und dass alle gleich
behandelt werden
coppola sie können eine nachfrage
stellen wenn sie möchten vielen dank
frau präsidentin
sehr geehrter herr bundeskanzler scholz
vielen dank für diese für diesen für
diese hinweise ich werde dann noch mal
auf sie zukommen die zweite frage ist
unter den ruhe unter der roma minderheit
sind auch einige holocaust-überlebende
die bereits deutschland erreicht haben
wird es ähnlich wie bei den jüdischen
holocaust-überlebenden eine gemeinsame
evakuierungsaktion auch von
holocaust-überlebenden der
roma-minderheit
geben zusammen mit anderen
organisationen wie zum beispiel des
zentralrats
wir haben uns überhaupt verpflichtet
dass wir neben denjenigen die schutz
finden weil sie hierher kommen und
darüber haben sie gerade berichtet
darüber hinaus auch evakuieren vornehmen
die ganz ganz schwierig sind und sehr
sorgfältig vorbereitet werden es handelt
sich bei den holocaust-überlebenden um
hochbetagte
bürgerinnen und bürger der ukraine die
den schrecklichen holocaust überlebt
haben und deshalb natürlich unseren
besonderen schutz verdienen und wir sind
eng abgestimmt mit den europäischen
verbündeten im hinblick auf das was
getan werden kann um das zu organisieren
das sind ja auch ganz komplizierte
transporte wie man sich angesichts des
alters und oft auch der
pflegebedürftigkeit sehr gut vorstellen
kann
die nächste frage stellt der kollege
leif erik holm von der sp fraktion
vielen dank frau präsidentin herr
bundeskanzler die bürger und unternehmen
dieses landes warten dringend auf
entlastung von den explodierten
energiepreisen das entlastungspaket hat
ihre regierung versprochen und es ist
wirklich dringend notwendig ein
musterhaushalt erwartet in diesem jahr
etwa 3200 euro an mehrausgaben für
energie für strom gas wasser kraftstoffe
und das alles muss dringend abgefedert
werden wir sehen doch die ergebnisse
bisher schon wir sehen pendler die nicht
mehr zur arbeit fahren manches schmeißen
ihren job hin weil es sich einfach nicht
mehr lohnt und das kann so doch nicht
weitergehen deswegen braucht es eine
entlassung und zwar dringend in anderen
ländern um uns herum passiert das in
polen belgien in frankreich italien da
sind die linderung schon längst in kraft
wo bleibt das entlastungspaket ihrer
regierung warum schafft es deutschland
unter einem kanzler scholz nicht für
schnelle entlastung der bürger und
unternehmen zu sorgen
schönen dank für die frage sie
ermöglicht mir noch einmal das lob das
sie darin untergebracht haben hier zu
verstärken tatsächlich ist es so dass
diese regierung zwei entlastungs paket
bereits auf den weg gebracht haben mit
einem umfang von zusammen etwa 30
milliarden euro ich glaube dass das in
der dimension an der spitze dessen liegt
was in europa überhaupt organisiert
worden ist und wir haben unsere
entsprechenden möglichkeiten genutzt wir
haben bei dieser gelegenheit all die
verschiedenen
schwierigen lagen der bürgern und bürger
berücksichtigt wir haben etwas getan für
diejenigen die auf grundsicherung
angewiesen sind wir haben für
geringverdiener etwas getan mit dem
höheren heizkostenzuschuss wir tun etwas
für pendlerinnen und pendler mit einer
erhöhten entsprechenden
entfernungspauschale
wir machen etwas bad für die entlastung
bei den benzinkosten wir haben etwas
gemacht für diejenigen die auf den
öffentlichen nahverkehr angewiesen sind
wir haben steuerliche erleichterung auf
den weg gebracht was den arbeitnehmer
frei betracht den grundfreibetrag
betrifft wir haben etwas gibt auf den
weg gebracht für die familien eine
bonuszahlung und wir machen etwas als
sonderzahlung für die armen kinder in
dieser republik also da kommt eine ganze
menge zusammen danke dass sie es gelobt
haben der eine teil ist schon auf dem
gesetzgebungs fahrt der andere folgt
jetzt schnell hinterher und wenn sie
mithelfen kriegen wir auch die
gesetzgebung b zweiter dritter lesung
und zustimmung des bundesrates mit
eiltempo durch bundestag und bundesrat
hier haben sie haben das recht seiner
nachfragen mit verlaub herr
bundeskanzler aus ihren worten spricht
der blanke hohn für diejenige wenig geld
verdienen und 3300 euro möglicherweise
an mehrkosten in diesem jahr haben und
die davon eben noch nicht in weiten
teilen entlastet sind ich habe die
pendler angesprochen ich habe noch nicht
angesprochen die fuhrunternehmer die
jetzt schon vor lauter not auf die
straße gehen mit ihren großen lastern
dort straßenblockaden errichten bei mir
in der heimat in mecklenburg vorpommern
beispielsweise und da sehen wir doch
dass es brennt an allen ecken und sie
sagen hier heute die entlastung kommt
bald auch beim sprit was ist denn das
ihr ressort abstimmung dann fertig wann
geht das gesetzgebungsverfahren los wir
wollen antworten die bürger wollen
antworten von ihnen wann kommt die
entlastung stolz also
dass sich die mühe machen könnten sie
die antwort aus ihren eigenen unterlagen
in dem das eine gesetzgebung paket ist
bereits auf dem weg und ich will
ausdrücklich sagen
lass ich mir schon öfter gedanken
gemacht habe über ihr
demokratieverständnis aber gesetze
werden in diesem land nicht von der
regierung sondern vom deutschen
bundestag gemacht und das ja
dann muss ich mal die durch sport
das fragerecht geht jetzt an die
kollegin annika merten von der fdp
fraktion
vielen dank frau präsidentin an die
kometen alles gut herr bundeskanzler der
ukrainische präsident lenski hat im zuge
der verhandlungen mit russland über ein
friedensabkommen im angriffskrieg
russlands auf die ukraine die
neutralität der ukraine im gegenzug für
sicherheitsgarantien der internationalen
gemeinschaft angeboten die
bundesregierung hat hierzu ihre
grundsätzliche bereitschaft signalisiert
sich an solchen sicherheitsgarantien für
die ukraine zu beteiligen
dies unterstützen wir ausdrücklich und
begleiten wir auch sehr gerne daher und
auch vor dem hintergrund dass bereits
auf dem eu-gipfel von versailles
erfolgten einstimmigen bekenntnis der eu
mitgliedstaaten zur unterstützung der
ukraine
auf ihrem weg in die eu die frage die
könnten solche sicherheitsgarantien
konkret aussehen vielen dank
in der tat ist es so dass gegenwärtig
verhandlung stattfinden der die frage
der neutralität eine rolle spielt was
das muss an dieser stelle gesagt werden
aus der sicht der ukraine ein großes
zugeständnis ist gegenüber dem aggressor
und bei allem was gegenwärtig in den
verhandlung stattfindet es mir ganz
wichtig zu sagen es darf nicht auf einen
diktat frieden hinauslaufen das muss
immer klar sein und wenn wir reden mit
der russischen seite wenn ich mit dem
russischen präsidenten rede dann mache
ich auch sehr klar es sind die ukraine
ukraine die über das was sie zu
vereinbaren bereit sind verhandeln
niemand sonst
in diesem zusammenhang ist die frage der
sicherheitsgarantien angesprochen
[Musik]
man sieht das große problem von olaf
scholz bei der frage wie er mit der
ukraine umgehen will denn die ukraine
sind wütend auf deutschland dass da
nicht klare ansagen kommen was die
sicherheitsgarantien angeht denn die
ukraine sagt nur wenn länder wie
deutschland und die usa und mit schützen
nach einem möglichen abkommen mit
putting sind wir wirklich sicher aber
bislang gibt der bundeskanzler darauf
keine antwort ja und bisher zu diesem
thema nur sein können
sie können eine nachfrage stellen ich
bedanke mich für die worte und hat sich
da auf die nachfrage
danke damit geht das rederecht an die
kollegin susanne ferschl von der
fraktion die linke
[Musik]
vielen dank frau präsidentin herr
bundeskanzler
ich hoffe sie haben sich mittlerweile zu
den fakten kundig gemacht mini jobs
verdrängen reguläre beschäftigung das
ist nicht bestandteil linker flugblätter
sondern es belegen wissenschaftliche
studien allen voran die des erb- und sie
führt insbesondere bei frauen dazu dass
dienen darf teilzeit falle feststecken
beides schließen sie jetzt letztendlich
in einem koalitionsvertrag aus
versprechen also da dass es nicht zu
einer verdrängung kommt das ist nicht zu
einer teilzeit falle kommt und die frage
wie wollen sie das versprechen
realisieren wenn sie die mini jobs aber
gleichzeitig ausweiten
das was in deutschland stattfindet ist
etwas über das ich sehr froh bin wir
haben endlich in aussicht eine
gesetzgebung über einen höheren
mindestlohn von 12 euro der in diesem
jahr noch kommen wird der wird dazu
führen dass viele viele millionen
arbeitnehmern und arbeitnehmern mehr
geld verdienen als sie gegenwärtig
verdienen
in diesem zusammenhang haben wir ein
festes verhältnis für die höhe des
termini jobs im verhältnis zu dem
entwicklung des mindestlohns beschrieben
das ist ein stück rationalität für die
zukunft aber wir haben genau wegen der
von ihnen gestellten frage uns auch
gedanken gemacht wie kann man den
übergang möglichst gut organisieren
damit niemand der jetzt wegen des
höheren mindestlohns mehr geld verdient
gewissermaßen sich irgendwie gewicht
fühlt darauf zu verzichten jetzt
sozialversichert beschäftigt zu sein und
deshalb ist das ein teil des
gesetzgebungsvorhabens dass wir auf den
weg gebracht haben hier die kleine zone
noch freundlicher auszugestalten mit der
klaren perspektive jeder höhere lohn
soll auch zu einem höheren
nettoeinkommen führen dass es die
zielsetzung
die kundennachfrage danke frau
präsidentin der bundeskanzler
mindestlohnes das entsprechende
stichwort die mini jobs bei einer
gleichzeitig fehlenden
arbeitszeiterfassung sind das
haupteinfallstor beim mindestlohn betrug
und sie warten jetzt auf der einen seite
die minijob regelung ausführen aber
nicht die manipulationssichere
arbeitszeiterfassung 1 das heißt wir
wollen sie sicherstellen dass nicht
weiterhin millionen beschäftigte um
ihren ihnen zustehenden mindestlohn
betrogen werden und wie wollen sie dafür
sorgen dass die erhöhung auch
entsprechend bei den kolleginnen und
kollegen ankommt auch die arbeitszeit
von minijobbern muss dokumentiert werden
da gibt es keinen unterschied zu
denjenigen die normale
arbeitsverhältnisse haben deshalb meine
teile ich ihre prämisse nicht und
selbstverständlich gehört auch zum
arbeitsleben wie im öffentlichen leben
ansonsten auch dass es notwendig ist
dass recht und ordnung auch durchgesetzt
werden in diesem fall recht und ordnung
auf dem arbeitsmarkt und die dazu
notwendige behörde ist den letzten
jahren beständig ausgebaut worden und
wird auch weiter ausgebaut werden sage
ich hinblick auf den das vorantreibenden
hinter mir sitzen den bundesminister der
finanzen wir werden den zoll und die
finanzkontrolle schwarzarbeit so
ausbauen dass sie sich darauf verlassen
können wir gegen algen betrugsversuchen
hinterher
nächste fragestellerin ist die kollegin
dagmar andres und der spd fraktion
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr bundeskanzler unbestritten
ist der krieg in der ukraine eine
ungeahnte herausforderungen
beispielslose art und damit auch eine
bewährungsprobe für den zusammenhalt
innerhalb europas egal ob jetzt aufgrund
der wirtschaftlichen und sozialen folgen
auf grund der flucht bewegungen oder
auch aufgrund der akuten militärischen
bedrohung durch russland vor diesem
hintergrund möchte ich sie fragen in
welchen bereichen ist europa jetzt
besonders gefordert und in welchen
bereichen eröffnen sich durch diese
krise womöglich auch neue spielräume
neue chancen um den europäischen
zusammenhalt weiter voranzubringen und
können sie bitte konkretisieren welche
impulse die bundesregierung hier in den
nächsten wochen und monaten setzen wird
schönen dank
angesichts der ukraine krise kann man
sagen hat sich der russische präsident
ja mehrfach verrechnet er hat sich
verrechnet in hinblick auf den
widerstand der ukraine ukraine dieses
die russische invasion ja
zurückgeschlagen haben im verhältnis zu
dem was da ursprünglich intendiert war
wie das weitergeht das können wir alle
hier nicht vorhersagen aber das was dort
an widerstand geleistet worden es war
sehr groß aber er hat sich auch
verrechnet in hinblick auf die einigkeit
von uns allen auch die einigkeit der
europäischen union die sich an den
global vereinbarten sanktions paketen
mit großer wärme beteiligt hat sie mit
vorangetrieben hat und diese einigkeit
müssen wir jetzt nutzen für große
fortschritte in europa damit dass ein
momentum ergibt es weit darüber hinaus
geht aus meiner sicht ist es wichtig
dass wir jetzt solidarisch mit den
herausforderungen umgehen die sich auch
durch die russische aggression und die
wirtschaftlichen folgen auch der
sanktions entscheidungen ergeben und das
bedeutet wir müssen zuallererst dafür
sorgen dass europa was die
energieversorgung betrifft auf eigenen
füßen steht und sich unabhängig macht
von fossilen ressourcen insbesondere den
notwendigkeit kohle öl und gas zu
importieren genau das tun wir mit den
paketen die in europa besprochen werden
und das ist der eine große notwendige
bausteine für fortschritt und einigkeit
in europa
sie können an den nachfragen stehen sie
verzichten dann
geht das fragerecht über an den nächsten
kollegen das ist florian hahn von der
cdu csu fraktion
sehr geehrter herr bundeskanzler
sie haben vorhin ausgeführt dass
vorgängerregierungen noch nie waffen in
krisengebiete
geliefert hätten möchte an der stelle
daran erinnern dass die schwarz rote
bundesregierung
2014 waffen in das krisengebiet irak
konkret an die per schmerker kurden
geliefert hat zum übrigen gottseidank
und mit großem erfolg die frage ist also
was es mit ihrer aussage von freund zu
halten richtig ist auch dass die ukraine
schon länger
waffenlieferungen gerne hätte aus
deutschland und auch ihre regierung erst
sozusagen mit dem eintritt des krieges
sich um entschieden hat und diesen
waffenlieferungen diese
waffenlieferungen genehmigt hat ist das
richtig wir sind die regierung die diese
entscheidung getroffen haben und die
reden entscheidung ist richtig
also die vorgängerregierung hat das auch
japan wickeln nachtragend herr
bundeskanzler ich möchte sie außerdem
fragen es gibt eine große diskrepanz
zwischen dem was wir
öffentlich wahrnehmen was die
bundesregierung auf der einen seite
selber postuliert im sinne von wir
liefern so viel wie geht und dem was auf
der anderen seite auf der liste in der
geheimschutzstelle zu sehen ist oder was
auch tatsächlich in der öffentlichkeit
zu lesen ist oder auch was die ukraine
tatsächlich sozusagen als feedback auf
diese lieferungen gibt meine frage ist
wie kann es sein dass wir über so viel
wochen praktisch keine veränderungen
haben bei der ausfuhr von waffen mit
blick auf die entsprechende liste in der
geheimschutzstelle und wie passt das
zusammen mit
den äußerungen der bundesregierung und
wie passt es damit zusammen dass sich
die
bundesverteidigungsministerium damit
rühmt das deutschland der zweitgrößte
unterstützer beim thema
waffenlieferungen ist nach den usa
obwohl bekanntermaßen andere länder
deutlich mehr geliefert haben
schönen dank für ihre frage erst mal ist
es so dass wir in der tat viel liefern
wir haben am anfang das gemacht aus den
beständen die wir von in der bundeswehr
haben und die verfügbar sind und die
sich um waffen drehen die auch sinnvoll
sind und die auch einen ganz erheblichen
beitrag geleistet haben zu dem
militärischen aktivitäten der
ukrainischen armee spreche hier von den
panzer abwehrwaffen zum beispiel den
flugabwehrwaffen viel munition und
vielen was dazu gehört und wir sind
dabei jetzt gewissermaßen die bundeswehr
um deren stärkung wir uns ansonsten ja
auch noch gedanken machen damit sie in
zukunft viele bestände hat die viel
größer sind als heute dass nebenbei
welche möglichkeiten existieren für
industrielle lieferung darüber haben wir
sehr sorgfältig all die verschiedenen
angebote der industrie betrachtet und
bewertet und unsere vorstellungen dazu
entwickelt und sind jetzt im engen
austausch mit der ukraine was dort
wirklich ist sie wissen dass wir im
übrigen alles dafür getan haben dass
auch die finanziellen
handlungsmöglichkeiten der ukraine dazu
groß sind die eu hat mittlerweile eine
milliarde euro bereitgestellt für die
beschaffung von waffen und das ist auch
richtig
die nächste fragestellerin ist die
kollegin lisa war dumm aus fraktionen
bündnis nutzt
[Musik]
ja das war jetzt gerade sehr spannend
denn florian hahn der abgeordnete der
cdu csu fraktion hat auf eine geheime
liste hingewiesen auf eine liste die in
der sogenannten geheimschutzstelle des
bundestages lager nach unseren
erkenntnissen sind dort weit mehr als
zehn positionen aufgeführt von waffen
die die ukraine ganz dringend braucht
und der bundeskanzler hat darauf wieder
mal sehr nebulös geantwortet die frage
war klar warum tut die bundesregierung
nicht mehr warum arbeitet sieht diese
liste die in der geheimschutzstelle
league nicht konsequent ab und die
antwort hat olaf scholz nicht geliefert
einmal mehr die erkenntnis auch hier die
bundesregierung stand zumindest das muss
man sagen über wochen auf der bremse in
bezug auf waffenlieferung
müssen aus ihrer sicht die ambition
nochmal angeschärft werden damit wir
letztendlich unabhängiger und damit auch
unverwundbare werden
es gibt wie ich eingangs gesagt habe
zwei
unterschiedliche fragestellungen zu
beantworten was machen wir schnell und
unmittelbar um die abhängigkeit von den
russischen importen zu reduzieren da
geht es auch um investitionen für zum
beispiel flüssiggas terminals an den
norddeutschen küsten und ähnliche
entscheidungen die etwas mit dem import
fossiler ressourcen zu tun haben bei dem
flüssiggas terminals ist das gute das
wir sie sowieso brauchen nämlich für den
später geplanten import auch von
wasserstoff der zu einer klimaneutralen
industriellen zukunft um die mitte des
jahrhunderts für europa spätestens 2 45
in deutschland dazu gehört und deshalb
ist es für uns ganz ganz wichtig dass
wir genau in diesem bereich die
notwendigen fortschritte jetzt zustande
bringt unser stromnetz ausbauen dafür zu
sorgen dass wir ein ordentliches
wasserstoff netz bekommen dafür sorge zu
tragen dass wir produktionskapazitäten
bekommen für windkraft auf hoher see
für solarenergie für die möglichkeiten
die damit verbunden sind das machen wir
auch in dem wir die
möglichkeit mehr auf strom zu setzen
verbessern indem die kostenbelastung die
mit der eeg umlage für die stromnetze
rinnen und nutzer heute verbunden sind
abgeschafft wird aber das machen wir
eben auch mit einem massiven boom bei
den investitionen das ist der weg den
deutschland geht wo wir heute einen
wichtigen schritt für gegangen sind aber
es ist der weg der für ganz europa
richtig ist
sie können eine nachfrage stimmt ja
vielen dank herr bundeskanzler
insbesondere auch für die ja soweit also
die erste regierungsbefragung von
unserem bundeskanzler olaf scholz
weiterhin bei uns im studio politik chef
jan schäfer jan hat olaf scholz den gute
figur gemacht in deinen augen hatte
antworten geliefert also hat auf einige
konkrete fragen die es gab eben keine
konkreten antworten genannte ein
beispiel dass viele zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer sicherlich auch interessiert
ist das thema entlastungspaket da gab es
eine frage aus reihen der afd und die
war nicht relativ konkret und das ist
ein punkt den ganz ganz viele ja
interessieren wann genau kommt diese
entlastung eigentlich bezogen auf
senkung der energie steuer beim benzin
beispielsweise bezogen auf dieses 9 euro
ticket für busse und bahnen und auch da
hat olaf scholz einmal mehr eigentlich
drumherum laviert nach unseren
informationen soll es der erste juno
also der erste juni sein aber das hätte
olaf scholz sicherlich auch sagen können
denn wenn man sich das
gesetzgebungsverfahren anschaut dann ist
das eigentlich der termin der angepeilte
ist er merkt wahrscheinlich selbst dass
das angesichts der explodierenden
spritpreise aktuell ein termin ist der
viel zu spät essen und dann ist ja auch
beim thema waffenlieferungen einmal mehr
relativ
deutlich geblieben und hat eigentlich
nicht das gesagt was viele sich erhofft
hatten einmal klar zu sagen was denn
eigentlich jetzt genau passiert welche
waffen zusätzlich kommen wie man konkret
die ukraine unterstützen wird auch da er
im ungefähren da waren wir auch noch mal
nachfragen bei paul ronzheimer der hat
ja nun auch zugehört ganz zu beginn
paule hat der bundeskanzler gesagt wir
liefern doch alles was an gefragt wurde
was sagst du dazu
da gibt es unterschiedliche angaben ich
kann auch nur wiedergeben was die
ukraine sagen die deutschen sagen was
anderes ist sieht nach chaos aus
teilweise soll minister in lam bericht
dafür verantwortlich sein aber man kann
nur hoffen dass es dann wirklich endlich
vorangeht und dass dann auch alle
gemeinsam versuchen da jetzt wirklich
diese waffen hierher zu bringen ich kann
es nicht sagen ein wem es liegt ich bin
weit entfernt hier was oder scholz rede
dort angeht oder die befragung angeht
fand ich einsatz am anfang bemerkenswert
wir haben ja gerade eine debatte um die
tagesschau die öffentlich rechtlichen
die immer noch von mutmaßlichen
kriegsverbrechen butscher sprechen und
da hat olaf scholz gottseidank lage sagt
das sind kriegsverbrechen das fand ich
einen richtigen und starken satz
schwieriger fand ich hinterher wie er
auf die sicherheitsgarantien reagiert
hat denn die wahrheit ist olaf scholz
und deutschland möglicherweise
wenn man fragen würde sind nicht ist
nicht bereit dafür die ukraine zu
verteidigen auch in dem moment nicht
wenn es eine friedensverhandlungen gebe
das war ja die frage und das ist das
worüber die ukraine spricht ich glaube
da hat dann die ukraine auch die
wahrheit verdient ist man bereit ja oder
nein es ist eigentlich eine relativ
einfache frage jetzt hatten wir vor
analysiert und gesagt olaf scholz wird
diese frank vermutlich kennen die ihnen
dargestellt werden es war ja wirklich
breit gefächert da waren auch fragen zum
thema minijob dabei und auch zu unserem
thema flüchtlinge hattet ihr beiden das
gefühl dass er die frage wirklich vorher
kannte oder hat er auch relativ gut
spontan reagiert
jan vielleicht du zuerst ja also das war
diesmal durchaus etwas anders da kamen
die fragen er spontan das hat man auch
gemerkt an der moderation der bundestags
präsidentin bärbel bas und wie es sich
für eine regierungsbefragung gehört in
diesem rahmen gab es natürlich dann auch
eine frage zumindest nur das war der
linkspartei ganz ganz wichtig glaubt
ganz generell kann man sagen etwas was
wir in den vergangenen tagen erlebt
haben innerhalb der ampelkoalition das
hat olaf scholz auch deutlich gemacht
noch einmal das thema waffenlieferung
wird aus meiner sicht mittlerweile doch
mit einem wirklich stärkeren
focus jetzt verfolgt also auch wenn olaf
scholz da auf der bremse noch ein
bisschen gestanden hat oder auch vor
allem die verteidigungsministerin in der
vergangenheit hört man doch ganz klar
von grün und auch von fdp seite dass da
deutlich mehr passieren muss und da
scheint es offenbar so als wenn die
beiden kleineren fraktionen und die
beiden kleineren regierungspartner den
bundeskanzler da auch ganz mächtig
treiben pauli frage noch mal an dich
hättest du dir mehr schärfe bei den
fragen gewünscht
ja ich glaube schon dass von der
opposition da teilweise nicht die frage
angesprochen wurden die eigentlich
momentan die bevölkerung bewegen und die
auch sozusagen hier die menschen bewegen
noch viel stärker hätte ich mir fragen
zu dem thema waffenlieferung gewünscht
und auch die aufklärung woran lag es
denn jetzt denn das ist ja wichtig um es
besser zu machen also was wusste er über
xy also ich finde die abgeordneten haben
es nicht geschafft in irgendeiner form
olaf scholz in die enge zu treiben oder
mehr informationen zu bekommen und dann
hätte ich mir mehr grundsätzlichkeit
gewünscht über die frage von
deutschlands rolle in der welt was sind
wir dann bereits zu tun was sind wir
bereit sind bereit unser land am ende zu
verteidigen was ist mit unserem warum
ist die in so einem katastrophalen
zustand und ich hätte mir fragen
gewünscht zur vergangenheit zu frage und
der rolle von frank walter steinmeier
wie olaf scholz diese bewertet auch von
alt kanzlerin merkel und dem russland
kurs der gibt es immer noch keine
aufarbeitung eine kritische aufarbeitung
dieses russland kurses dieses shooting
kurses der vergangenheit ist dringend
notwendig danke danke auch die jan hier
im studio für diese einordnung für diese
einschätzung von euch beiden die erste
regierungsbefragung von unserem
bundeskanzler olaf scholz wir machen
eine kurze pause sind gleich wieder für
sie da